so you might have seen this tweet
hungarian is a gender neutral language
it has no gender pronouns so google
translate automatically chooses the
gender for
you here is how everyday sexism
is consistently encoded in 2021 f you
google on the left hand side is a
hungarian
sentence google translate then
translates this
to the following text saying she is
beautiful he is clever he reads
she washes the dishes he builds she sues
he teaches she cooks so google translate
chooses the gender pronoun and it
appears to
choose gender pronouns that are very
consistent with
common gender stereotypes so this has
generated
a lot of outrage and the topic is coming
up again and again
and i thought we just dig a little bit
into the background of
why this happens and what we might do
about it
so the first thing you might notice is
the text here is really
a bouquet of stereotypes and also ends
with
go to hell google so no doubt this
person has
tried a bunch of things so i've kind of
reproduced the first
four sentences of the input and here it
is
she is beautiful he is clever he reads
she washes
the dishes now to detect whether or not
this
is a feature of the language maybe there
are subtle gender hints
here is a thing you can do you can
translate it
back into the other direction she is
beautiful he is clever which will give
you the hungarian sentence
and then we can simply change the
pronouns right here
he is beautiful she is clever if there
are subtle language hints
you would expect that if you translate
this to hungarian
and back that the same sentence returns
however if this is a truly
gender-neutral language
then you would not expect this to matter
so if we now translate this to hungarian
and then we take this hungarian sentence
and translate it back
oh see it has actually switched around
the pronouns
back to she is beautiful he is clever
so no doubt google translate here is
inferring
the pronoun from the words that follow
assigning beautiful to a more feminine
pronoun
assigning clever to more masculine
these are gender stereotypes and we're
going to dig a little bit into
why this happens for that we have to
understand
how the machine learning systems
currently work
machine learning systems are statistical
systems
that try to translate a piece of text
into a piece of text of a different
language so here we
enter the piece of text in one language
it goes into this big ml box and out
comes actually not a single sentence
but out comes usually a plethora of
possible sentences along with
probabilities
assigned to each of those outputs the
system then
chooses the most likely output and
displays that to the user
i already said this is a statistical
system it is derived from a set of
training data so it's important to
understand that all the system does
is tell us that the sentence she is
beautiful
is the most likely sentence to appear in
a document
that is translated from hungarian where
this original sentence
was present given the training data the
training data itself
is of course derived from the world in
some way if you believe that such a
thing as reality
exists and there we have the whole
system so now we might ask ourselves
what do we do about it how should we fix
this
and the answer unfortunately is it
depends
it depends on where you think the
problem
lies so the first point where there
could be a problem
is the way we derive the training data
from
the world or from reality itself
common issues here are that the sampling
of data
is somehow skewed it is out of date
we're working with old data
in general the data that we have does
not reflect the world
and if the data that we have is skewed
in some way
we can only expect that our machine
learning system picks up on that skew so
a person arguing this
would say that it is actually not that
likely
that these sent hungarian sentence here
translates to
she is beautiful and it might be equally
or more likely that it translates to
something else
if we only had all the translation data
that we could
hope of the second point where we could
introduce problems is
when we derive the ml system from the
training data here's the thing
every machine learning system introduces
statistical
biases in order for it to generalize
properly otherwise we could not do
learning and it's entirely possible that
some of these things such as the
regularizer and the loss function or the
particular choice of architecture
would introduce statistical bias into
the system
this would result in a model that does
not reflect
the data as we have it so someone
arguing for this
would argue that even though we have
good training data in the training data
there is no problem the ml system
derived from the training data
introduces unwanted effects so someone
might argue
even though the feminine version here is
slightly bigger
in the training data than the masculine
version
through the process of learning and
distilling the ml model simply abstracts
this
and makes it a lot more likely therefore
skewing the gender balance
unfairly the last problem is the fact
that we simply
choose the top prediction and output
that to the user this is not really
accurate if we simply output whatever is
most likely this is an unfair
representation
in fact what we should do is we should
give the user
all the possibilities with all the
probabilities associated someone arguing
for this
might say that the training data is fine
the ml model even makes
good outputs the probability
distributions are
correct and reflect the world however
because we only pick the top one the
user is
tricked into thinking that that is the
only possibility or maybe just
that this possibility is much more
likely than the alternatives
as good as that sounds to output always
the probabilities associated with
different ambiguous translations the
short answer of why we don't do this
is pragmatics i'll give you an example
this
is billy billy it's a chinese video
sharing website and for people who
cannot access youtube from china
i do upload my videos to billy billy so
they can watch them however while i'm
practicing mandarin i'm not good enough
yet to navigate a site
that is full of characters that i have
even a difficult time parsing
and this is what google translate is
usually used as i just want to navigate
effectively to the point where i can
upload a video define its categories
leave a description
and then send that off if google
translate were to give me
every possible ambiguity of every
translation
how could i possibly achieve my task and
this all breaks down if you just think
one step beyond the things like gender
if there is ambiguity in a translation
and you give me all the outputs what am
i supposed to know i go to google
translate because i don't know what
something means and especially if you
don't give me
actual probabilities together with the
possibilities
i have no clue what to do but let's go
into this a little bit more
see if we go to this original sentence
and explore google a little bit more
you might ask why is not even consistent
across the entire thing i input google
splits by sentences it's pretty clear
because once you hover over it
you get the different sentences right
here you can solve this by
inputting a comma in which case at least
within a sentence
the translation is consistent this is
not always the case
but it gives you a little bit of a hint
on how google translate
works moreover if you just input a
single word
google will actually give you the output
distribution
over all the translations here the
second thing is
if you input an entire sentence and it
has a gender pronoun
google actually gives you both versions
and it says that translations are gender
specific
it is only when you input more than one
sentence
that this doesn't work anymore in fact
if i make this into
one sentence google gives me both
versions
and this is already the corner case
because
technically it should give me every
combinatorical version
of the different assignments of these
four variables
right here so you can clearly see that
google is doing everything it can
to give you a good practical solution
that still makes sense
in the majority of use cases people use
google translate because they want to
get an idea
of what something in a language means
that they don't understand
they don't go to google translate to
draft their formal letters
that must be absolutely correct so i
think the accusation against google here
and
saying things like fu google and
honestly google has found a super
pragmatic solution
and i think they're just doing the best
they can in the face of the overwhelming
complexity
that is machine translation all of that
being said there is a
fourth category a category of people
that says that
even if we derive the training data
correctly and it reflects the world even
if
our algorithm does not introduce any
additional
bias even if the output probability
distribution is the correct probability
distribution for that translation
this is still not good because
they see the problem here in reality
itself
it is reality that doesn't conform to
some preconceived
notion and this might have multiple
reasons for example
a person arguing this might argue that
if we output the correct probability
distribution
that might have some downstream effects
or
it might reinforce these stereotypes or
a number of other arguments someone
arguing like this
would see ml models more as tools for
social engineering which is a valid
stance to have
not criticizing that any of this
pipeline is wrong but that the original
bias that exists in the world is carried
over
into these outputs and we should change
that
in order to affect the world now while
that is valid stance to have
and certainly debatable you have to ask
yourself whether you really
want to give google a multi-billion
multi-national corporation the almost
monopolistic power
to decide on what's good and bad for
society and personally
i'm gonna go no with this one in any
case what i want you to take away from
this
is that there are many possible places
where problems can be
introduced and therefore many possible
points
where we can introduce solutions but
what we
have to be careful of is that we don't
confuse the different points and we
don't let people
provide evidence for one particular
point of problem
and then suggest a solution that is in
an entirely different
area all right that was it from me i
hope this was
at least a little bit entertaining
[Music]
bye-bye
you